good afternoon my name is Charles
caption I'm a senior fellow here at the
council and I have the pleasure of
presiding at today's luncheon event our
speaker today is Neil Ferguson he will
be discussing his new book the cash
Nexus money and power in the modern
world 1700 to 2000 recently published by
basic books
neil is currently a professor of
political and financial history at
Oxford University and also a visiting
professor professor of economics at the
Stern School of Business New York
University he is the author of paper and
iron the house of Rothschilds the pity
of war and virtual history and he is
currently working on a major new history
of the British Empire since Neal is one
of the most prolific authors around
we're expecting this new book by the end
of next week let me also say that Neal
was here about a year and a half ago to
discuss his book the pity war on World
War one my blood pressure is still
elevated from that discussion of
Germany's role in the war I must be a
glutton for punishment because I'm
coming back for more
anyway it's my pleasure to welcome Neal
to the Council
well I'm sorry about your blood pressure
Johnny I'll try and do something to
bring it down perhaps I should say sorry
in Chinese not accepted try again
you have no hostages um it's a great
pleasure to be back at the Council on
Foreign Relations and thank you to ever
be responsible for I invited me and
thank you to everyone who's come for the
quickest lunch in town today I want to
begin with a brief explanation of the
title of my book the cache Nexus when I
first proposed calling the book the
cache Nexus a number of people in London
looked surprised and said but I thought
that was a make of car and I spent a
good deal of time trying to persuade
people that the word Nexus which is AB
Latin origin means essentially a nought
or link was an appropriate word for a
book about the relationship between
finance and politics believer the theme
of the book like me it's a phrase that
comes from Scotland was Thomas Carlyle
who coined it in 1840 when he wrote a
wonderful essay from past and present
entitled in which he argued and I'll
summarize his argument that cash payment
was not the sole nexus between man and
man Carlyle sense was that the incipient
industrialization of Britain and indeed
the world threatened to transform all
human relationships into economic
relationships and his argument was
against that that the cash Nexus was not
the sole relation between people and in
a way that the underlying theme of the
book which sets out to question the
primacy of economics or the primacy of
finance in political life
and not only in international relations
but also in domestic politics going
right back to the early 18th century and
in some cases further back than that
it's also a book which attempts to
address a Tolstoy n' question Tolstoy is
great question at the end of warrant
peace is what is power and that's really
the key question that I found myself
addressing inspired by Carlisle I was
asking is power financial power does
money really makes the world go round
as I think we've all come perhaps only
subconsciously to assume it's the
economy stupid a phrase that must haunt
Al Gore as he tries to understand what
went wrong when according to every model
of electoral success that the political
scientists have produced he should have
romped home to to a landslide at the end
of last year what I want to talk about
today before our discussion and I'm
going to try and keep it as brief as
possible so that we have ample time for
discussion is the International aspect
of the book I'll spare you
elections I think elections fatigue is
probably fairly well-established in the
u.s. today I want to address very
briefly three of the questions in the
book first is there a harmonious
relationship between democracy and
capitalism between democratization and
the spread of free markets are they a
kind of magical double helix a virtuous
upward spiral should we be confident
about the future as both the free market
and democracy appear to be spreading
inexorably round the world my second
question how far is it possible to have
economic globalization without some kind
of political global power without to use
a very dirty word imperialism and
finally is there a danger of overstretch
that all great powers must be fearful of
a question raised in my mind some years
ago by Paul Kennedy's splendid book the
rise and fall of the great powers to
which in some senses the cash Nexus is
an extended report if we go back as far
as it's possible to go back in the
history of per capita income and the
history of democratization there is at
least a clear coincidence between the
rise of per-capita income and the spread
of democratic institutions around the
world back in 1800 if you do the numbers
as some excellent economic historians
have heroics they attempted to do per
capita income expressed in 1990 dollars
was about 250 dollars this is for the
world as a whole the average annual
income of an individual in the world in
1800 today it's risen exponentially to
2,500 an extraordinary growth most of
which occurred in the 20th century in
fact and there's a similar upward curve
if one tracks the spread of democratic
institutions around the world
there's a wonderful database the polity
3 database are discovered which attempts
to quantify the spread of democracy
since 1800 and apart from some rather
alarming interruptions in the 1930s and
1940s it looks like another upward
ascent back in 1800 according to their
scale of how democratic are you marks
out of 10 no countries scored above 6
out of 10
in the last few years for the first time
in history more than half of countries
in the world score above 6 out of 10 on
the democracy scale so it looks like a
happy ending and that I suppose was one
of the arguments Francis Fukuyama made
in the end of history now in the book I
try to suggest that this coincidence of
the spread of of prosperity and the
spread of democracy needs to be looked
at very much more closely than it has
been before we conclude that there is
some happy causal relationship one way
or the other between economic growth and
democratization but I don't want to
label that point today for me the really
critical argument and the one that means
the ending is not necessarily happy and
isn't an ending is the fact that
democratization appears to be associated
in many parts of the world with an
increase of internal conflicts within
multi-ethnic societies and this seems to
me to be the fundamental catch
underlying the spread of prosperity and
the spread of democratization it's a
catch I could illustrate very easily
with another wonderful upward ascending
chart only this time the rising curve
measures the number of civil wars in the
world for most of history certainly
going back into the 1800s civil war was
the exception most wars were between
states and the number of civil wars in
the world was around 5 on average for
most of the 19th century sometimes a
little more but today and this has been
true only for around 10 years the
majority of wars in the world are civil
wars they are wars within States very
often wars which have their origins and
ethnic conflict is this simply a
coincidence rising prosperity rising
democratization
and increasing civil war I don't think
it is there's some very illuminating
work by Harvard political scientist
Alberto alle Sina
which argues that this is not so
surprising that as democratic
institutions come to multi-ethnic
societies from Yugoslavia to Indonesia
one of the first things that happens is
that instead of falling into the kind of
peacefully resolve herbal parliamentary
disputes that we expect as Britons and
Americans to happen on the democracy
what happens is that conflicts between
ethnic groups very quickly take on a
violent character and cannot be resolved
through parliamentary debate much the
same happened and explains the great
crisis of democracy in Central and
Eastern Europe in the 1920s and 1930s so
we have in a sense been here before
democratization appears to be associated
when we take the global view with
increasing civil conflict and as a
consequence with political fragmentation
and political fragmentation is one of
the great problems of our time and it is
an inevitable consequence of the
proliferation of civil war back in the
time of Bismarck there were about 60
recognisable States political States
nation-states empires call them what you
will as of today the number is closer to
190 and rising even we Scots have to
contemplate the alarming possibility
that in our own lifetimes we may find
ourselves the People's Republic of
Caledonia prospects that terrifies me
and should tell her terrify the English
even more this in other words is the
catch simply giving the world prosperity
and democracy may not necessarily and
appears not to lead to a happy ending
they don't all live happily ever after
on the contrary as das desk
he said wonderfully they fight and fight
and fight and fight and that he said was
the one certainty in human history
this it seems to me has profound
implications for globalization that
buzzword of our times now much of the
literature on the history of
globalization seeks to draw parallels
between globalization 100 years ago the
last great age of commercial and
financial global integration and
globalization today what I want to do
very briefly is to suggest some of the
key differences not only in the
economics of globalization but also in
the politics of globalization comparing
pre-1914 or let us say 1901 with 2001
the biggest difference of all seems to
me to lie in the different roles played
by what we laughingly called the top
nation in 1066 and all that Britain as
top nation had a quite different
relationship with the rest of the world
compared with the relationship between
the United States and the rest of the
world today in economic terms it is a
striking fact that exports that trade
with the rest of the world played a
vastly bigger role in the British
economy in 1900 then it plays even today
in the US economy 25 percent of gross
national product was roughly what
exports accounted for for Britain before
the First World War
compare that with a figure of around 7
or so percent in recent years in the US
and even more importantly Britain was a
great capital exporter the world's
banker lending investing abroad on a
colossal scale yet today's global
hegemon the United States is a great
borrower the world's great debtor if you
look at net foreign investment as a
proportion of gross domestic product for
Britain before the first world war it
was a positive 9 percent a colossal
level of capital export but the United
States in the last 10 or so years
has shifted into being the greatest
death the same figure the equivalent
figure sir
net for an investment as a proportion of
gross domestic product is minus 15
percent for the u.s. today so the global
hegemon today is not a great lender not
a great investor but a great borrower
honoring from abroad to finance the
greatest consumption boom in all of
history
and a third important economic
difference once upon a time the global
hegemon exported people a colossal level
of migration out of the British Isles
lay behind that transformation of the
world economy that occurred in the 18th
and 19th centuries even on the eve of
the first world war between 6 & 8 per
thousand of the British population
emigrated each year of course I don't
need to tell you that the United States
is a mirror image of Britain before the
first world war today the United States
is an importer of people as well as of
cash now in discussions of globalization
that is usually where the story stops
trade finance migration but I want to
emphasize the importance of exporting
and globalizing institutions this was
something about the which the British
were never at all embarrassed and yet it
seems to me and perhaps this follows
logically from what I've said about the
different economic roles played by
Britain and America the export of
American institutions is happening if
it's happening at all in a far more
informal way than the export of British
institutions in the 18th and 19th
centuries the Pax Britannica was based
on the formal direct rule of about a
quarter of the world's population and a
quarter of the world's land surface area
I was trying to devise a way of
comparing British formal power with
American informal par today and I was
trying to find a map that I could
compare with those wonderful maps that
all British classrooms used to have
of the world colors pink no such maps
appear to exist with as it were a tiny
little pink basis to characterize
America's formal Empire so eventually I
found out that there are approximately
70 military bases overseas which the US
Armed Forces presently maintain in fact
nearly half of them are in Western
Europe and the overwhelming majority are
in Germany and indeed a Martian looking
at this imaginary map of American formal
rule would conclude that the principal
objective of American foreign policy in
the year 2001 is to control Germany
clearly the most potent threat to US
interests today this is a tremendously
anachronistic distribution of resources
that have been dwindling rapidly since
the mid 1980s one of them are striking
statistics that the cache Nexus has to
offer is that there was between the mid
80s and the late 90s in real terms our
decline in American military expenditure
of the order of a third at a time when
that need to drastically REO reinstate
American foreign policy
probably logically demanded higher
rather than lower expenditure we are in
the midst of an enormous period of
restructuring but this restructuring it
seems to me in American foreign and
defense policy is being done on the
cheap the question I find myself
addressing when I posed the toss durian
question what is power came back to Paul
Kennedy's theory of the late 1980s that
the United States ran the risk of
imperial overstretch he drew an explicit
parallel with Britain in the 1890s the
the weary type and yet it seems to me as
it did then to be a mistake to imagine
that the sources of British decline lay
in excesses imperial or military
commitments
and rather what I argue in the book is
that if we want to explain what went
wrong with British power in the 20th
century the better answer is that it lay
the problem lay in under stretch in the
failure of British liberal and
conservative politicians alike
adequately to prepare for the great
threat to British global power that was
being prepared in Germany from the 1890s
if not before under stretch lead the
British Empire open to an assault
through the backdoor through Belgium
towards the channel which it was wholly
in equipped to repulse and the costs of
which in the course of the First World
War rendered the British Empire from
that moment on a profoundly financially
vulnerable an institution under stretch
in other words is the danger that great
powers face not overstretch and I try to
show in the book that it's a myth that
excessive military expenditure has ever
posed a threat to the United States
economy far more serious is the risk the
risk that the British ran that in
complacently assuming that you dominate
the globe you underestimate the dangers
that are developing not so far from your
own back door and this brings me to my
concluding reflection it's a reflection
which has a moral as well as a pragmatic
financial tinge to us the question that
I find myself asking as I completed the
cash Nexus as I contemplated the
enormous material wealth of American
Society of Americans as individuals was
simply this Americans clearly have the
cash they have the resources but do they
have the will in fact in the book I
wrote the guts
to make the world a better place by
analogy in the way that the British
Empire sought however unsuccessfully to
export British institutions even to
those godforsaken parts of Africa that
we all know on the map but never visit
even by analogy with that Carlile got it
right cash
II wrote later has not all power and
those Americans who imagine that here on
Planet Nasdaq they are for the future
seen eda a global superpower without
rival may be in danger of succumbing to
that great delusion that ultimately sank
British power thank you very much for
your attention
we will now turn to Q&A for the balance
of our time let me try to impose at
least a little bit of structure on the
conversation by suggesting that we spend
about 15 minutes on some of the broader
arguments that Neil makes about the
connection between power and finance
critique of the Democratic peace and
then turn to and segue into some of the
more contemporary claims that Neil is
putting forward particularly on the
nature of the American polity and the
claim that he ended with namely that the
United States should be willing to
expend more blood and treasure and
putting out Pax Americana but that it is
unwilling to do so is the right in that
assessment and if so why and what can
should if anything be done about it
please when I call upon you state your
name your affiliation and pose a brief
questions I would like to go first
sir could you wait for the microphone my
name is joel coen I'm at Rockefeller and
Columbia University's tiny little resort
I'd like to ask whether you think that
the rise in civil wars which accompanied
the rise and incomes and rise in
democratization could alternatively be
explained as a delayed echo of the
collapse of colonialism which drew
borders around countries without respect
to the wishes of the occupants of those
countries and put together people who
were not well disposed toward one
another would that be if that were an
explanation then the rise in civil wars
would be a transient effect until
countries resource ensel way but it is
that plausible
it's a good question Joe I'm not
convinced that the answer is yes for one
simple reason that lurking behind your
question is is the great American
assumption that self-determination will
ultimately deliver the happy ending of
homogeneous nation states I think the
idea that absent colonialism somehow the
map of Africa would eventually have
formed into something more like a
patchwork quilt of smaller tribal
nation-states is a highly questionable
one and the notion that civil wars
arises because the borders are in the
wrong place is I think doing a violence
to what
certainly the British attempted to do as
they decolonized let's take a an obvious
example of how borders were drawn on the
basis of self-determination in the great
scuttle from India over which
Mountbatten presided the problem the
great conflict that welled up at the end
of British rule in India was really a
consequence of the assumption that there
should be a kind of self determining and
religiously homogenous partition of
India now I think the problem is very
well illustrated again if you look at
Central Europe
by the way in which the peacekeepers at
Versailles assumed a shortcut took to
harmony would be to attempt to create
self determined nation-states in the
rooms of the Hapsburg and even the
Ottoman Empire problem is that the
ethnic map of the world just never was
like that and the question of how
political units should be drawn and how
far they should be based on
self-determination seems to me to be the
big question that Western policymakers
in general have been ducking for the
better part of a hundred years if the
model is the homogeneous ethnically
homogeneous nation-state then we have an
awful lot more civil war to come almost
incalculable amount and a great many
more petty states that do to be formed
I don't think that can be blamed on in
effects colonialism I think it can be
blamed on the application of the
principle that Matt seen Ian
self-determination and 19th century
European notions of nationalism and I
think our real failure and decolonizing
was to contemplate the possibility that
their ethnic Li homogeneous nation-state
was not the correct model for the rest
of the world even if it had been to
Western Europe placed in the back
Thank You fret tips and here at the
council I'm sure you're aware of the
argument to detect foreign affairs
published an article not long ago that
in fact the incidence of civil war has
actually gone down in the last ten years
not up but I wonder if you have a
response to that but my question has
more to do with the difference between
the position of Britain a hundred years
ago in the position of the United States
in the sense that Britain was faced with
the challenge to the system conducive to
its own security from great power
challenges the Germans and others in
Europe particular where as isn't it the
case today that the United States with
all due respect to those who think that
China or even Europe may become great
power challenges to us the problem for
us and in the system that is conducive
to our security is one of weakness and
not power it's that it's the collapse
and the deterioration of States not the
ascendance of great powers that
confronts us well I quite agree with
that second point on the question of the
incidence of civil war it's always a
mistake and here I speak as an historian
you must remember that I'm not an expert
on current affairs and I'd be violating
the trace description Act if I claimed
to know much about the present under I
know about the past and the one thing I
do know is that ten years is not really
a long enough sub period for us to make
any generalizations about the instance
of civil war like to talk about 200
years and what one is most struck by one
one simply tries to add up the amount of
conflict within borders is this vast
increase in the period from around about
the mid 1980s
I don't think the decline is anything
like enough in the last couple of years
to justify talk of a decline in civil
war indeed I think we're already seeing
developing in countries like Indonesia a
whole new wave of strife of an ethnic
nature which will make Yugoslavia look
like a teddy bears picnic I mean the
second question you asked is is
absolutely correctly framed of course
there are no great power arises
I read the Secretary of Defense's most
recent report to Congress the other day
which rather half-heartedly suggested in
a pair
about future threats to American power
that the main contenders were indeed
China and Russia and if if that is the
most that the United States has to worry
about and we can all relax and go home
clearly this is not a world like the
world of 1901 and one when already it
was clear that economically and
militarily for Britain faced serious
competition and not just from Germany
but also from Russia and even to a
lesser extent from France and Japan the
United States it's a different world and
here I think we need to go further back
in history to understand quite where
America currently stands we needs I
think to go back as far as 1815 a time
when Britain emerged from the Napoleonic
Wars to find everybody else bankrupt all
the other great powers on on their
uppers and Britain alone as the kind of
inner in a completely unique position of
economic and military superpower this
was a kind of mana puller world and it
remained as such for much of the 19th
century despite occasional skirmishes of
the periphery of the Empire with with
the Russian to a lesser extent with the
French and I think this is a much more
of a a parallel it's a parallel also in
the way that the United States can fight
short peripheral Wars very much in the
way that british gunboat diplomacy
operated in the age of Palmerston so the
Americans today have the option to wait
gunship diplomacy and altercations and
muted apologies towards China really
form a part of the same pattern the
difference seems to me is still one of
will and perhaps also resources the
British looked at trouble spots they
looked say it western Africa as indeed
we look at Sierra Leone today and
concluded that something had to be done
to prevent large parts of the world
descending into a kind of permanent
anarchy I think the impulse in the
United States today is simply to look
away from these kinds of mess and regard
them as simply not relevant to the
interests of the American electorate or
the interests of the British electorate
never mattered terribly much to
Palmerston but they mattered enough and
the impulse of the British electorate
most obvious when you consider the
where they campaigned the destruction of
slavery in the slave trade within
Britain's sphere of influence was a
crucial fact it's that moral impulse the
moral impulse to do good abroad which
seems to me so much weaker in America
today next question
right behind you is the microphone
well-heeled and RK solar do you lament
the collapse of the austro-hungarian
Empire
do you lament the death of Tito
is there going to be a third question
try to guess I think we get where he's
going well
Gladstone once said show me anywhere on
the map one place where Austria has done
good and I think I'm too much of a
father of a liberal at heart to lament
the passing of austria-hungary which
especially since it was so woeful II
self-inflicted they did choose the means
of their own destruction and they choose
chose the most terrible I think it's
extremely dangerous to lament a passing
of any great multinational entity of any
great Empire sometimes I'm accused and I
thought this would be your third
question of lamenting the passing of the
British Empire I don't think that's
really the function of the historian
these institutions were in a sense
self-deceit and I think the same applies
to Tito one cannot simply wring one's
hands and say oh if only they had
retained an authoritarian regime in
which ethnic conflict was submerged was
kept down by the iron fist that simply
isn't and wasn't an option I think the
question we have to ask ourselves is
whether there's any way that the kind of
institutional assumptions we make in
Britain and even more in America about
the need to establish democracy is there
any way that we can adapt our techniques
to the reality of ethnic conflict in
disintegrating multinational entities
and I think there has to be it's very
clear looking at the ruins of Yugoslavia
today that if we are to avoid Perpetual
a recurrent ethnic cleansing there needs
to be a self-confident prolonged foreign
presence in the contested areas Bosnia
Herzegovina and Kosovo we are going to
be there for a long time and the great
problem that this raises in American
minds is but that's not democratic and
we cannot run mandates or a colonial
policy
in a region like the Balkans and at the
same time say that we're for promoting
democracy and my response to that is the
rule of law first democracy second and
we need decades to establish the rule of
law to establish the habit of settling
disputes through courts and Parliament's
rather than with machineguns then so be
it
the great danger it seems to me that has
underpinned so much American
intervention ISM in the last 10 or 20
years has been its short-term nature the
exit strategy is already being discussed
before the troops have even been sent in
there can't be quick exits in these
situations in a sense we have to build
our own austria-hungary's we have to be
our own teachers if we're to prevent
certain regions of the world becoming
permanent genocide or nightmares and
that I think is the harsh conclusion
which very few Americans are certainly
view very few American voters are
prepared to accept next question
Jonathan Paris Oh would you wait for the
microphone
Jonathan Paris a couple of few years ago
I co-edited a volume called the politics
post Suharto Indonesia so I want to take
you where you're already going and
suggest that ethnic conflict if you go
to Singapore you'll find hatred between
Chinese Indians and Malays as strong as
anywhere in Indonesia but that the
Malays the Malaysians and the
Singaporeans had the luxury of being
British colonies Indonesia had the
misfortune of being a Dutch colony
and by that I mean that you see the rule
of law the court system the legal system
the development of institutions much
more firmly settled in the in those
first two countries than in Indonesia
and what Suharto was able to do was to
collapse all of the weak institutions to
begin with around his family and if he
became like a mayor of Chicago and so to
speak so when he left
you had no institutions to hold in to
reign in the the latent ethnic tension
whereas in Singapore if you're if you
walk around in your car
with a knife you could get capital
punishment so you have a very strong
overlay of authoritarian rule of law so
the question is given that Indonesia
doesn't have historically the British
experience how can they get this under
control just latent ethnic tension under
control without bringing in another
Suharto well I wish I had an answer to
that question I think it's the most
alarming prospect for Asian stability in
the foreseeable future I confess to not
being an expert as you are on Indonesia
and in the sense I very rapidly retreat
into what I know from the foreign pages
of the Financial Times which is probably
a good deal less and most people know
here let me try and answer that in a
kind of historical vein I think the
interesting thing about the legacy of
British Empire is that we can't assume
it's permanent there clearly was
certainly into the 1960s an obvious
correlation between political stability
and British presence as opposed to the
presence of other colonizing parts which
generally speaking did not do the job so
well of establishing the rule of law the
tragedy and it's most obvious in a
country like Zimbabwe former Rhodesia is
that these institutions no matter how
firmly they were established ultimately
can be and are being demolished and
there's nowhere in the world where the
rule of law is being more systematically
destroyed than in regardez Zimbabwe
today so in a sense even even the
conclusion are at least a British if you
like a British legacy gave a country a
chance of establishing stable and
institutions and stable rule of law even
that hope seems to me to be one that
wanes as time passes I'm not sure what
is going to happen in Indonesia my hunch
is though that there will not be another
Suharto unknowable would be another
British M
capable of imposing peaceful resolution
and that what we are likely to see in
them in future is a great deal more of
that ethnic conflict which rules has
already become such a a terrifying
aspect of the poster heart era I'm in
tantor in the middle of the run
as the colleague of yours Timothy Garton
ash spoke here and he wrote a book which
is a useful complement to yours a
history of the present I think he comes
out a bit more optimistic than you that
even without the intervention of a Pax
Americana there would be the spread of
democratic values over ancient hatreds
in spite of the fact that that empires
like the Yugoslav Empire began to
disintegrate in the 10 years he studied
how would you compare your thesis with
Timothy Garton ashes yes I I've great
admiration for Tim Goff Nash he's a very
good friend of mine I question whether
you can be a historian of the present
and his claim at the beginning of that
excellent book that he has the advantage
over future historians of having been
there strikes me as highly questionable
to say the least this is of course his
great disadvantage when it comes to
understanding the future of the Balkans
close reading of what Tim writes about
Kosovo for example reveals firstly that
his position has changed between
editions of the New York Review of Books
secondly that his experience of being
there he confesses this himself is
really part of that phenomenon we know
in Fleet Street as war tourism which is
that you fly in as the great commentator
talked to a few people pose for a few
snaps and then head back to the security
of since a Deniz College Oxford to write
it out and finally the great he was a
friend
you want to hear what he says about
clean and finally when the great theory
emerges from these observations it is
that sooner or later all European states
will be ethnically homogenous statelets
and I think he says then in a footnote
interestingly just to prove that he is
really an academic that there's a law
and the law is that any state which has
ethnic minorities accounting for more
than 20% of the population is in the
long run not viable which is a really
hard line Matt simian kind of view of
the self determining nature of political
culture and I just think that's wrong I
think it's wrong because if we believe
that then we are heading for a really
very very torrid 21st century I also
don't think that it necessarily follows
from what has been happening in say
Bosnia has a governor there are parts of
the world you just can't split up into
ethnically homogeneous states other than
at unacceptably high human cost so in in
the cash Nexus I question the Garton ash
theory which which although it's
temptingly simple doesn't seem to me in
fact to square with what is it
politically desirable in the foreseeable
future
now I sentence if I was really
rubbishing him there which I didn't mean
at all to do because I think he is a
brilliant journalist a brilliant writer
and when people come to try to
understand the history of the collapse
of communism they will be referred by
historians to guard Nash's commentaries
particularly on what happened in Poland
which are brilliant and and I think
unique but it's not history it's
something different from that it's the
primary sources from which history will
be written but I think maybe Tim is
deluding himself in thinking that you
can write history there and then as it
happens Joel
Thank You Joel motley um the heart of my
question goes to the tension between
military activities and major Wars and
democracy and our history I think is you
know pretty sharply marked by these
tensions when we've had to mobilize of
his Civil War was the work worse but
over one World War two where they're the
political cost if you will of repressing
certain views and so forth and the
trade-off between spending money and
other things is quite severe and this is
in your own history as well and perhaps
back to the Greeks where people talked
about how democracies are very slow to
get going for war but once they do they
do a great job so there is this inherent
difficulty and I think you ought to
perhaps help us by reflecting on that a
bit with her you know
Churchill to Roosevelt talked about the
frustration of getting ready for World
War two because the society was just
fundamentally not a military and maybe
the hour will permit me to bring the
question current to say that while the
bases in Germany look like anachronism
zuv the last war as a European perhaps
you can enlighten us on the sense of
some of us have the fear of a united
Germany with a new attitude that it
doesn't have now happily but could have
is still a very real threat for Russians
and Eastern Europeans and in our our
presence there is not really just a
throwback but maybe a very current means
of keeping the lid on well thank you for
those questions I'm mindful at the time
so I'll try and answer them as
succinctly as I can um the great problem
you were absolutely right and something
that the book tries to tackle the great
problem that the hugely wealthy but
increasingly democratic Britain and the
Democratic United States faced in the
20th century was the despite being
Kannamma clean substantially wealthier
than their their potential so
they're democratic institutions tended
to cut defense spending in peacetime and
ruled out the kind of precautionary
military mobilization that might have
made a real difference in the run-up to
1949 in the run-up to 1939 when
particularly Germany was not
sufficiently deterred at to risk a
European conflict I have thought a lot
about this and come flickin clusion that
this is really the fundamental problem
of 20th century history that
authoritarian regimes and I kind of
simplify this by talking in terms of of
a kind of anglo-american model in which
democratic institutions are our
paramount and setting priorities and
attack a totalitarian model in which an
undemocratic elite can mobilize a
society using coercion and propaganda
well in advance of any external threat
this is the fundamental problem namely
that although these totalitarian regimes
are economically way inferior can never
compete economically with the Western
economies they are superb at destruction
in a sense they're they're not
interested ultimately in production
their real strength lies in destruction
that's what's they're good at and the
initial damage done in the first phases
of both the world wars by the
non-western powers to use a simple
shorthand is staggering when you work
out the net body count in the world wars
really by air by that measure Britain
and her allies should have lost both
wars because the Germans and their
allies kill vastly more people than they
lose of their own and that's the duck
that is the trouble you really don't
need a great par with the equivalent GNP
of the United States to be threatened a
relatively small rogue state can inflict
horrendous damage thanks to the enormous
growth of destructive technology in the
late 20th century it can inflict
colossal damage on an unprepared
economic superpower and in the sense
coming back to an earlier question well
what are the threats
I think the threats are quite different
the threats can be carried in a
briefcase
and in that sense you know the United
States is actually more vulnerable than
the British Empire was to incredibly
cheap hugely destructive technology that
can be deployed a by rogue States more
or less at will and to me the only
amazing thing is that terrorism hasn't
become more of a feature yes of American
life but I'm certain it will Larry Larry
court from the council let me follow up
on that because one of the criticisms of
Kennedy's book was that he took an
unnatural period right at between the
end of World War two in the start of the
Cold War then he said Americans share of
GDP a world GDP drop but if you go back
and look at average it return to normal
let me follow it up with defense Betty
you picked the highest year of American
spending in the Cold War period you take
a look at what we spend on average in
the Cold War its 325 billion dollars
that's exactly what we spend today so
there has been no no real decline simply
if you take the example of the bases we
are in those bases not to to deal with
the situation in Germany they're jumping
off points we have tried to get bases in
other parts of the world we lost their
bases in the Philippines when I was in
government we tried like heck to get a
lot of bases in the Persian Gulf air we
have limited access and so the idea that
the United States is not doing what it
should doesn't really add up now we you
might argue as you just did that we're
preparing for the last war with these
forces that we buy or not dealing with
the real threats but it's not for lack
of effort and not for lack of
understanding the problem yes thank you
also did me the service of answering
that second question
the previous speaker raised which I
completely ducked inadvertently I'm
sorry about that it wasn't it wasn't
anything other than absent-mindedness on
my part um briefly defense expenditure
the real measure that matters in fact is
is not adjusted for inflation but
adjusted for economic growth and a 2.9
percent of American gross domestic
product the current defense budget is of
the GNP and and in fact then we would
still be protecting our you know our
interest around the world you I mean you
can't penalize this country for having
tremendous economic growth in the 90s
and with that with that measure no but
you can say that a country that is
enjoying enormous economic growth has
the capability to increase its military
capability and I think that's really my
point that allowing the defense budget
to in relative terms to decline to a
point lower than at any time since the
interwar period I mean almost we're
heading towards a situation when the
number of Americans in the armed
services as a proportion of the
populations as low as it was in a before
the American Civil War it's an
extraordinary demilitarization that
we're living through now it seems to me
the problem with that and the problem
with what you've just said about the
military bases is simply one of what is
actually doable now if a major collapse
of order were to occur in Asia
say in Indonesia if the stability of
America's allies were to be threatened
by minor rogue states it seems to me
clear that the American military though
is it absolute terms the best resourced
in the world would be extremely hesitant
to intervene the interventions that have
occurred in the last 10 or so years have
been strikingly shortened duration and
the emphasis on minimizing casualties as
I think genuinely impeded at what the US
has prepared to do while at the same
time there isn't really a willingness on
the American part to allow multinational
institutions under the auspices of the
UN to do more by simply paying
Ukrainians and others to act as
mercenaries in countries like Sierra
Leone or or or Randa so I do think that
it's a legitimate question to ask if
America enjoys the highest level of
prosperity in all history who did not be
prepared to consider using a proportion
of those those resources for something
other than purely national defense and I
think that's really the issue whether
one takes some of the slack that's
created by the boom years and thinks
seriously about devoting it to not just
peacekeeping but peacemaking
in those areas of the world which are
simply heart of darkness territory
that's essentially a moral question it
has nothing to do with the national
interest it's a question really of
responsibility and the responsibility
that comes with undreamt off well there
are quite a few people that want to have
at you and we have only a short time
left I'm gonna cluster a few questions
and then come back to you for a final
statement David please keep here our
questions as short as possible
David David Marvin what n want you I was
just wondering whether drawing all these
comparisons with Britain and so forth
may miss the point I don't know I may
miss the point but in any case we don't
it seems to me have said is our priority
not extending our institutions
particularly to other parts of the world
I mean democracy can take a number of
different forms we're not extending an
empire we're not extending communism
we're not extending Nazism as those
countries tried to do or the Japanese in
their way what we're trying to do is set
up a different international a different
set of international institutions to
which all can be comes with which all
can become so entwined I'm talking about
WTO's and IMF's and all the others that
we're experimenting with a asia-pacific
economic coordination and so forth that
it will develop self interests on the
parts of all these other countries that
to cooperate to some degree in order to
save their economic livelihood and that
we have armed forces residually in a way
large though they'd be to take care of
the cases of countries that you
mentioned that aren't willing to do the
economically sensible thing or Somalia's
that collapse though it's gone on
collapsing since we love and other
countries that may require some support
to get out of dead end situations of
ethnicity by the way the minorities in
the United States are now beyond 30
percent and we don't seem to worry
you've been waiting for a while do you
still want to get in Charles Ferguson I
would just ask you whether you think
that perhaps the increase in ethnic
strife might be consequent upon the lack
of equitably distributed education and
economic opportunity in many nations
which in turn might be the result of
previous military and political
occupation and secondly if you could
provide examples of drawing on your
historical knowledge of situations in
which the long term military occupation
of foreign nations resulted in the
betterment of their social and economic
condition I'm gonna take the opportunity
to post the final question and then ask
you to sum up I share your conclusion
about the importance and the
desirability of the United States
putting the pedal to the metal and
running trying to run the show it's
probably the most stable world that one
can imagine it's worked very well for
the last several decades I just don't
think it's possible and I don't think
it's possible largely because of
American domestic politics a set of
institutions a constitution that doesn't
really have the same sort of
internationalist inclinations that other
countries do in part because of our
history in part because where we are and
so I fear that if the United States were
to pursue this sort of grand strategy
that you
advocate it would overreach you would
end up in a position where we pursued a
foreign policy for which there was no
domestic support and then we end up
where Woodrow Wilson ended up trying to
aspire to a level of engagement and
ending up with nothing
well thank you for those questions I
have a tiny amount of time mere minutes
to answer them I'll do my best
the danger of assuming that economic
integration the mighty power of credit
will ensure world peace is very well
illustrated by two books one Norman
angels great illusion and the other the
recent book by a New York Times
journalist Thomas Friedman all the three
in the Lexus or was it Nexus not Nexus
both books argue that that in a sense
economic integration and and global
financial integration will will bring
about a new era of peace that Golden
Arches theory of democracy that says no
two states will go to war with one
another if they both have branches and
McDonald's was actually disproved within
days of the book's publication in in
Britain by the the bombing of Belgrade
and I think the the problem with the
Norman Angell view which is absolutely
what you are have just argued that we
can allow economic interrelationship to
usher in the new year of peace is the
problem that was wrong with arguing that
in 1911 but it isn't actually enough the
Dostoyevsky in point they fight and
fight and fight seems to me to be and
that's really the whole point of the
cache Nexus to be something that simply
offering trade and investment cannot
trump violence will happen people will
not all flock to Walmart in preference
to buying a Kalashnikov and having at
one another and at some level American
foreign policy has to put aside this i
think economic determinist utopianism it
is not going to be enough simply to let
the World Trade Organization make
everybody trade to abolish war
and the issue really seems to me not
about the imposition of democracy that's
a contradiction in terms but the
imposition of the rule of law and
perhaps also the ensuring of improved
education certainly when Robert Barron
did his great study of the determinants
of economic growth in the post-war world
that the most interesting results were a
that democratic institutions didn't
matter but the things that did matter
were be at the rule of law and see
education of particularly education as
it turned out of men rather than women
I've never understood quite how he
arrived at that finding but he did so in
a sense we have to be clear what the
objective is you can't just sell the
rule of law it's not a product that you
can buy at Walmart and people won't buy
it necessarily voluntarily the issue
really is how can it be imposed in those
parts of the world and there are a great
menu where it's not wanted and I think
only of the recent events in Albania
Macedonia of Sierra Leone of East Timor
Indonesia think of the genocide in
Rwanda which was allowed to happen while
the Security Council the United Nations
fiddled niro like its back turned and so
one could go on there are a great many
trouble spots and the attitude seems to
be at the moment we will intervene and
are completely ad hoc basis where we
feel we can do it quickly and with zero
casualties it's not enough somebody asks
for an example I think it was as you of
a country that had benefited from long
term for an occupation I'm sorry India
as a sixteenth dancer for you time
running out
and can I end by agreeing with with my
chair
the real problem and the reason now you
can actually have another half hour of
course the reason that I end the book
with a question about American will
relates precisely to those chapters that
deal with democracy and its internal
ailments the chapter that deals with the
decline of healthy political parties as
a phenomenon not only in Europe but in
the u.s. the chapter that deals with
campaign finances are a real source of
instability within the mature
democracies I am ultimately pessimistic
as you are about the willingness of
American voters to contemplate any
American GIs
so much as sustaining a scratch in a
country like Sierra Leone and I think
that's why one comes back to the future
of the international institutions the
extent to which we can make the united
nations work if the United States isn't
willing to act on its own behalf in
these trouble spots and I conclude with
a statistic the combined budget of all
United Nations programs all United
Nations activities currently amounts to
1% of the u.s. federal budget which
institution has the real power that's
the real cash Nexus Thank You Neil for
an intellectual feast